on entend beaucoup de choses quand on
dit qu'on va être maîtresse de cérémonie
moi j'ai entendu des trucs
le truc que j'ai tous entendu ses
ouailles je comprends pas non c'est pas
faim les césar c'est très bien les
housses car c'est tellement lieu gs
d'américains ils font des shows à
l'américaine
oui les américains et parlant de l'est
couramment ils sont trop forts ces des
antes orthez une wii mais les américains
ils sont gros alors c'est quand vous
voulez les gars soit on a une silhouette
qui ressemble à quelque chose un peu la
lune soit en bouffe des chips devant la
télé puis on fait des films sur des
robots qui se transforme en bagnole moi
ça me dérange pas non mais c'est vous
qui voyez moi j'ai choisi jours